je suis donc alinghi bris je suis
consultante en développement durable je
suis aussi l'auteur du livre zéro
plastique 0 toxiques et je suis ravi
d'être là ce soir
d'autant que je vais vous parler de ma
poubelle je vous rassure c'est beaucoup
plus intéressant que ça n'en a l'air il
ya quatre ans j'étais une jeune
étudiante de 19 ans j'allais au
supermarché pour faire mes courses
j'habitais dans un studio où j'ai étudié
et sert à rien de plus classique
un jour une amie m'a envoyé un article
sur le zéro déchet alors c'était
l'histoire de cette jeune new yorkaise
de 25 ans qui pour des raisons
environnementales avaient décidé de ne
produire quasiment aucun déchet pendant
plus de quatre ans alors moi au début
devant cet article j'étais vraiment très
sceptique je me disais mais où est ce qu
elle fait ses courses elle n'a
probablement jamais sortir de chez soi
de chez elle et ne rien consommer
pourtant cet article a été loin de ne
rien apprendre et d'avoir aucun effet
sur moi j'ai notamment compris qu'en
fait nos poubelles ont un impact énorme
sur l'environnement j'ai appris que nos
décharges sont responsables de plus d'un
tiers des émissions de méthane d'origine
humaine c'est un gaz à effet de serre
extrêmement puissant j'ai aussi appris
que ces mêmes des charges créé des jus
très toxiques lors de la fermentation
des déchets j'ai aussi appris dans cet
article que les incinérateurs produit
des fumées extrêmement toxiques qui sont
filtrées mais seulement en partie
et en plus de ça ces incinérateurs sont
plein de fumée toxique qui vont être
filtré ces filtres représentent des
déchets très toxique très dangereux à
traiter
j'ai aussi appris un chiffre j'ai appris
combien un français produit en moyenne
de déchets en une année je vous rassure
moi non plus je m'étais jamais posé la
question
alors pour voir d'ailleurs effet
certains d'entre vous savent combien en
moyenne un français produit de déchets
en une année entre 360 kg par année 260
kg et 160 kg qui dirait 360 kg à main
levée ou qui dirait 260 kg par année
rien n'a beaucoup moins et qui dirait le
160 kg personnes malheureusement c'est
bien la majorité qui a raison puisque
c'est très exactement 3 164 kilos de
déchets qu'un seul français produit en
une seule année
alors j'ai ainsi réalisé également dans
cet article que nos objets jetables du
quotidien c'est à dire les emballages
alimentaires les cotons les rasoirs etc
représente en fait une consommation
énorme de ressources naturelles prenons
l'exemple des cotons démaquillants
jetables pour produire un seul kilo de
coton
ce sont cinq mille deux cents litres
d'eau qui sont nécessaires et pourtant
c'est coton les utilise une fois avant
qu'ils finissent leur vie à la poubelle
j'ai donc réalisé une dernière chose
avec toutes ces informations en poche et
cette chose c'est peut-être la chose la
plus importante que j'ai réalisé dans
cet article
moi qui me disait si écologique parce
que j'ai acheté des produits divers et
que je triais mes déchets je me suis
retrouvé bien bête devant mon énorme
poubelles de 30 litres que je
remplissais à moi salue chaque semaine
j'ai aussi réalisé que par là il y avait
un énorme écart entre mes valeurs c'est
à dire ma conscience environnementale
mon désir d'agir et les impacts réels
que moi j'avais sur l'environnement par
mal simple et innocente poubelle j'ai
alors eu envie d'agir mais pas
nécessairement de tout faire pas
nécessairement d'arriver au total zéro
déchet comme la jeune femme de l'article
mais plutôt de choisir quelques astuces
action recettes etc qui me plaisait pour
réduire petit à petit mes déchets et
donc mais impacts environnementaux
j'ai donc commencé par les cosmétiques
j'ai commencé en remplacer beaucoup par
des alternatives fait maison
mais j'avais toujours une règle d'or je
voulais des pensées ni plus d'argent ni
y passer du temps alors j'ai choisi
uniquement des recettes très simples
avec un ou deux ingrédients que pour la
plupart j'avais en plus déjà chez moi et
qui ne nécessitait aucun matériel alors
par exemple j'ai remplacé les baumes
pour les mains et les stick à lèvres par
du beurre de karité
j'ai remplacé mon déodorant par un
mélange très simple mais très efficace
de bicarbonate et d'huile de coco
j'ai aussi remplacer tout ce qui était
shampoing liquides et gels douche par
des shampoings solide et un savon solide
tout simplement
alors avec ses astuces très simple et
ses recettes
j'ai trouvé une alternative presque zéro
déchet a quasiment tous mes cosmétiques
et par cette petite expérience j'ai
réalisé trois choses à ma grande
surprise j'ai réalisé trois choses
premièrement en fait sans même le savoir
je protégeais ma propre santé
pourquoi parce que j'expose et moins
encore à des substances potentiellement
toxiques au long terme pour ma santé et
qui sont souvent présentes dans les
cosmétiques industriels deuxième chose
que j'ai réalisé c'est qu'en fait
remplacer ses cosmétiques réduire ses
déchets au quotidien et qui en fait
beaucoup plus simple que ce que je
pensais pas besoin par exemple d'avoir
un labo de chimie chez soi pour
fabriquer ces cosmétiques
il ya des recettes qui sont à la fois
très simple et très efficace
troisième chose que j'ai réalisé par
cette petite expérience c'est qu'en fait
ces cosmétiques étaient 100 écologique
presque zéro déchet et qui en fait
beaucoup beaucoup moins cher que ce que
je pensais
parce que j'utilisais des ingrédients
très bon marché mais à la fois très
simple quand plus j'avais déjà dans mes
placards de cuisine pour la plupart
c'est le bicarbonate pour les gâteaux du
citron des huiles végétales etc
et donc j'ai fait mes petits calculs et
avec ces ingrédients ses recettes très
simples
j'ai réussi à réduire mes dépenses de
cosmétiques
c'est à dire les baumes les crèmes les
déodorants et c'est à seulement 5 euros
par mois
alors ces trois petits trois constats
c'est à dire le fait que ce soit simple
sens économique
je mets effet quasiment à toutes les
étapes suivantes dans la réduction de
mes déchets après les cosmétiques je
suis passé aux produits ménagers je les
ai quasiment tous remplacés par un
mélange très simple d'eau et de vinaigre
blanc qui est naturellement
antibactérien et anti calcaire
j'ai ensuite essayé d'éviter le maximum
d'emballages alimentaires alors pour ça
j'ai acheté mes aliments secs en vrac
c'est à dire le riz les céréales les
noix etc
pour les autres aliments j'ai préféré le
marché les petits commerçants en bas de
chez moi puisque les aliments ils sont
très peu voire pas du tout emballé après
ça j'ai commencé à acheter d'occasion
mes vêtements mes meubles ma vaisselle
etc
j'utilisais le bon coin
j'utilisais des applis comme vintage ou
les bons vieux vide greniers ça me
permettait une chose ça me permettait
d'avoir des objets en parfait état sans
nécessiter la fabrication de nouveaux
objets et avec en plus de ça un prix
deux à trois fois moins élevés qu'en
magasin pour les mêmes objets après ça
j'ai commencé à remplacer petit à petit
mes objets jetables par des objets
réutilisables laval alors par exemple
j'ai remplacé les cotons démaquillants
jetables par des cotons démaquillants
lavables j'ai remplacé mon essuie-tout
par des bons vieux chiffons tout
simplement et c'est là aussi j'ai
réalisé que je faisais beaucoup
d'économies pourquoi parce que
j'investisse et dans des objets qui
dureront parfois littéralement 10 ou 15
ans ainsi au lieu d'acheter des objets
jetables de les utiliser une conne une
seule fois puis de les jeter et d'en
racheter et ses jeux fermer la boucle en
achetant un objets réutilisables une
seule fois et en le lavant et en leur et
utilisant sans jamais ni dépenser plus
d'argent ni jeter plus de déchets alors
tous ces petits changements dans mon
quotidien que ces petites astuces ces
petites recettes très simples à ma
propre surprise mon permis de réduire
mes déchets de 80% ces mêmes petits
changements m'ont permis de réduire mes
dépenses du quotidien c'est-à-dire
l'alimentation les vêtements les
cosmétiques les produits ménagers etc de
30%
ainsi par ma propre expérience j'ai
compris qu'en fait réduire ses déchets
et donc réduire ses impacts
environnementaux étaient en fait
accessible à tous et est accessible à
tous les emplois du temps et était
accessible à tous les budgets
alors ce constat j'ai pas été la seule à
le faire
à roubaix par exemple la ville organise
chaque année des challenge de famille
zéro déchet alors concrètement cd
challenge qui permettent chaque année à
des familles roubaisiennes de s'initier
à la réduction des déchets et pour la
quasi-totalité d'observer une
augmentation de leur pouvoir d'achat
ainsi beaucoup de familles roubaisiennes
au budget bis habituellement très
restreint ont pu se permettre de mettre
de l'argent de côté pour leurs enfants
et grâce au zéro déchet ainsi retrouver
de l'indépendance de la fierté et de la
dignité
alors maintenant si vous le voulez bien
j'aimerais vous fassiez une chose en
arrivant chez vous ce soir j'aimerais
que vous ouvriez votre poubelle
j'aimerais que vous y regardez ce qui
s'y trouve et j'aimerais que vous
choisissiez une deux ou trois astuces
action recettes etc qui vous plaisent
pour réduire petit à petit les déchets
que vous voyez dans votre poubelle
vous pouvez par exemple décidé de tester
de composter vos épluchures de remplacer
votre essuie-tout par des chiffons vous
pouvez éviter les fruits et légumes
préemballés en barquette etc
prenez toujours ce qui vous plaît les
actions les recettes qui pique votre
curiosité et qui vous font vraiment
envie et surtout n'oubliez pas une chose
l'objectif n'est pas nécessairement de
tout faire mais de faire votre part à
votre rythme et à votre manière
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]